did you know it was going to be released
on youtube for free and what are your
thoughts on that that was cool i didn't
understand at first why we would do that
instead of pitching it around then the
team all convinced me you know that it
was an interesting model that was an
emerging model that people are doing on
youtube to
you know not have any corporate
influences not have any bosses telling
them network notes telling them how to
tone down something or fix something or
it's not the way they like it
if you can make a show successful you
literally can create a comedy or
whatever kind of show you want that's
truly your vision unfettered so that's
nice and that seemed appealing to me and
a good use of my time if we could really
deliver it the way we wanted to
um
and people received it well then we'd
get to make more and more seasons and we
could just have this playhouse to go
nuts in this you know canvas that could
go anywhere
so that seemed exciting to me
the challenge is getting enough people
to see it so you can do a second season
because you don't have network money
behind it advertising it's hard to
spread the word
but
hopefully places like film cards can
help
good oh wow that's good i like that then
you know what that should be our
catchphrase
you